那我说这个话非常伤人啊，
以后少跟她来往，
你听话，
你乖，
以后少跟这样的女人来往，
这种女的真的自己不清醒，
托娘家人下水，
拖地弟下水，
托所有周围的人都下水，
跟你直播好几年了，
我这样，
那我是想跟我朋友咨询一下所一次带带小孩，
她可能不会有时间，
可不要想咨询一下她和她老公的分手的问题，
17年结的婚，
现在有一个8岁59岁的儿子，
还有一个两岁的女儿，
但是17年结婚之后就没有上班，
全是直在家带娃。
她老公是和她公公婆婆在山这里开了一个小的那个印刷转告那种小厂，
那是24年生完女儿以后的半年，
发现她老公出车了，
她出车的对象是她儿子的班里的一个家长，
刚开始的时候，
她老公是死不承认的，
后来是做在床呢，
她老公就一心求离婚了，
我开始以为这个是普通的，
后我是劝她离婚的，
然后来跟我讲，
她现在有两笔贷款，
她是离不了婚，
一笔是她三年前她与他的弟弟的房子抵押145个，
女方把女方弟弟的房子抵押出去贷款给她老公了，
对她女方父母也同意的抵了145个，
其中呢，
她有50个时候贷款，
她公公帮她还了50个全款，
抵的房子，
可能抵押的那个金额会大一点，
但一个之。
就是她老公开那个新发市场里，
她自己的做了一个营业执照，
在那个拼CCC上面搞了一个转现，
你那个营业执照又贷款了300个，
女方作为主体去贷了300个，
对，
等于现在有445个那个贷款，
他现在的话，
他公公是答应说我今年的农历年前把那个房子给他解套出来的，
那那个三宝哥的话，
他是暂时没有钱还，
今年二月份到期，
就是说还本金，
到期之后签了字就可以继续再每个月她老公在还利息，
她是贷出来的，
是给她的老公厂里做流动资金扩大业务的，
那她老公一年能挣多少钱呢？
这个她也不清楚，
她老公每个月之前是给她两三千块钱那个生活费，
我说一句冒天下之大不韪的话，
我知道我说这个话非常伤人啊，
也有挑拨离间的嫌疑啊，
以后少跟他来往，
你听话，
你乖，
以后少跟这样的女人来往，
这种女的真的自己不清醒，
拖娘家人下水，
拖弟弟下水，
拖所有周围的人都下水，
你少跟他来往，
我，
我跟她是高中同学，
认识他20年，
但是一辈子也得少来往，
要不然他拖你下水。
他现在的话，
去年是住娘家，
今年她爸妈劝她回她婆婆家，
因为她老公联系不上，
之前是答应每个月给夏天的上学费，
也不及时给我给她的建议是什么啊？
第一，
弟弟这一头不管是求证。
妥协着，
不管是跪着舔着，
也得让那头公公把弟弟的房子的贷款还完，
把弟弟姐套出来，
他自己欠那300万，
就这样吧，
上黑名单得了，
比如说他房子几套出来以后如果谈离婚的话，
他那个会变成夫妻共同财产，
应该150吗？
什么共同财产，
就是他如果离婚的话，
300万男方现在没有钱还吗？
你的这个闺蜜躲都躲不掉，
因为是以他的名义贷款的300万，
300万都在他头上，
躲都躲不掉，
他直接上黑名单，
做好充分的准备，
上黑名单我跟你说啊，
以后他在你面前哭惨，
他在你面前哭穷，
你要哭的比他还穷，
比他还惨，
你就是没有钱，
你千万不要借钱给他，
你千万不要耳根子软，
你千万不要说啊，
20年的闺蜜了，
我借你20万啊，
你不要那么蠢，
像你闺蜜这种女的，
这么拎不清的，
她的存在就是托周围人都下水，
你不要蠢，
你不要心软，
你一定要听龙飞的话，
她但凡向你哭穷，
但凡向你那个什么诉苦的话，
你就说你比他还穷，
你比他还苦，
你比他还没钱，
你比他还欠再多，
因为你救不过来。
300万你能还得起吗？
你还不起，
你但凡还了3万，
剩下他还想你，
让你再多还5万，
你还了5万，
他想让你多还15万，
你千万不要开这个口子啊，
嗯，
行，
你一定要去话办法呀，
没有办法，
他自己的名义去贷款的300万钱他不掌握，
一个月就给他3000块钱的生活费，
有的时候还不给他，
居然相信他的老。
老公会还这300万，
这么蠢的女人，
你有什么办法？
老天我老婆来了也没办法救她，
昨天我还了解了，
更生气她那个从女10万了，
她是女儿，
剩下红红的5万块钱红包，
还有她那个周莎莎里面她那个15万营业额，
她全是她老公了，
她一分钱都没有生下我就气死他就踏踏实实上黑名单，
就是釜底抽薪，
那他现在就是不离婚呢，
就啥子拖出来之后不离婚先拖着行不行？
可以啊，
反正都烂包成这样了。
嗯，
好了，
好，
谢谢你一定要听话啊，
你不要说什么江湖道义，
什么义气，
义气要给值得的人，
义气要给明白人，
义气要给有能力还恩情的人好不好？
嗯，
因为我看他这个性格就是属于那种江湖义气是吧？
帮着闺蜜出头，
帮着闺蜜出主意，
帮着闺蜜出气的那种义气一定要给值得的人啊，
像你闺蜜这种情况的话，
她太蠢了，
不值得了。
把自己弟弟的房子拿去抵押贷款给她老公，
她不了解她老公的经营状况，
也不了解老公一年能挣多少钱，
然后自己的营业执照，
自己的法人，
她去抵押，
她去经营，
贷贷300万给她老公，
不了解老公的收入，
不了解老公的经营状况，
给她老公不是蠢是什么？
记得点赞关注哦。